the chehalis tribe of western washington
state
is set to open the first legal native
american distillery in the country
they're calling it talking cedar the
tribe invested
25 million dollars into the talking
cedar complex
it features 35 000 square feet
with a restaurant brewery and the
distillery
after numerous legal and pandemic
related setbacks
talking cedar is set to produce 1.8
million gallons per year of 80 proof
spirits
including bourbon vodka and gin
the restaurant and bar opened the last
week of june
it's been wildly successful that's the
bar and restaurant portion
uh the brewery has been cranking out
some beer and the quality the response
that they're getting on the beers is
quite good and then the distillery you
can see
workers behind me behind the uh the
glass wall here are
you know putting the stills together the
distillery faced legal roadblocks
stemming from an 1834 law signed by
president andrew jackson that outlawed
distilling
on native american reservations the
tribe was literally 24 hours away from
issuing the notice to proceed
on the contract for the contractor to
start construction when they got that
notice from the bia
so it put an immediate fault to the
project
that was in february of 2018. we're a
lot of people looking around saying what
do we do with this information
that has been delivered by the bia
federal agencies are not necessarily
known for being creative
they are very much read what the
regulation is and go interpret that
what made it more frustrating was that
the statute even though it was still
technically in the books
some of the prior case law coming out of
the federal
courts said those statutes and the other
ones like it didn't really have any
effect anymore congress had gone through
in past
years and repealed many of those old
statutes at the same time that dealt
with
intercourse with tribes from the 1830s
but this one statute
didn't get repealed for some reason and
had never been enforced
we had never found it being enforced in
any uh similar judicial proceeding
we figured finally ironically the
fastest most efficient path forward
would be to go to dc and try and get a
federal law change
that's the fastest path forward and uh
so that's that's what we did
the chehalis along with justin stiefel
of
heritage distilling lobbied washington
lawmakers for nearly a year
until a bill was pushed through at the
end of the 2018
session and signed by president trump
this gave all 574 native american tribes
the right to distill liquor on their own
land
i'm i'm most proud of really two things
i'm most proud of that the tribe
trusted us to partner with us because
there are lots of people out there doing
lots of things the tribes
and this one is no different they have
access to resources and they
can make decisions on investments they
can go do lots of things
so the fact that they saw the value of
this plan uh in this proposal
i'm very proud of that and then you know
how can you not be proud of repealing an
old braces law from 1835 and how many
people are going to say they can repeal
a statute from
andrew jackson and so i'm proud that we
had a little hand in
trying to correct somebody history